it's funny everybody is talk everybody
talks about China so much in China in
Africa and the fact that um you know
Africans in quotes or like the different
people in different countries in Africa
should be aware because China has such a
bad human rights record and and like the
way I see it honestly I mean like is not
like dealing with the West has been that
great do you know I'm saying so you know
like why why should we be taking any
question people edit and I feel like I
mean I feel like it's not Africans who
are afraid of China's rise in Africa
it's the West that's afraid of China's
rise in Africa like for for Africans
it's a double-edged sword as is any
interaction there are a lot of positives
and there are a lot of negatives i mean
i think the hope is that with more
players in the game with more more
resources with more sources of capital
right and with more sources of ideas if
you are a leader with a vision in in any
one of the african countries now is the
time that you can actually you can
maximize right now is the time that you
have access to this set of you know
these sort of people who are willing to
work on these projects you have access
to these like now is the time to really
leverage your your your your resources
to relate to really bargain when you
have a chance to before you couldn't do
that and i think that's a good thing at
the same time one has to be very careful
because it's very clear that chinese
involvement is not on positive I mean
you look at the Chinese in Sudan right
that's definitely not positive and but
you look at for example the projects
that china is willing to work on and a
lot of things at the West won't touch
the Chinese are ready to do
infrastructure develop and the West has
been a lot of has been about extraction
the Chinese yeah they want oil that's
true no one's going to deny it but at
the same time like the projects that
they'll work on our our projects that
you know finalize just they need to
happen I mean like the roads need to be
built right railroads need to be built
and if it's this set of people who has
that scale and who have those resources
and have that ability then I don't see
why we shouldn't be talking to them
right and you know the you can bring up
human rights all you want and I think
what we need to do as Africans in our
various countries is make sure that our
leaders are are paying attention to that
and are trying to make sure that we're
not exploited in that way but I don't
necessarily think that it's that that
you know Europe or the United States has
really any right to say that these
people don't respect human rights when
the track record is just not very great
on their side the track record is
engrade on either side so it's up to us
as Africans to make sure that that track
record changes and you know whether
that's what the Chinese or whether
that's with Great Britain or with the
United States it's up to us to do that
and that's maybe where we're not pulling
our weight but as for the Chinese in
Africa I say if they're ready and
willing to come in then that connection
should be developed just responsibly
you